why did I cause the strike you cause
destroy you know what you're looking for
thought long and hard about it I so we
got to go on strike so there you have it
yeah the whole business is changing what
is changing to the internet and DVDs and
things like that to not get some that
seems kind of absurd yeah i mean the
strike seems to be important because new
media is growing so fast it's going so
incredibly fast it is so last year that
I go into a PC calm and there's a you
know it's free you can watch it for free
but there is a commercial before it and
somebody's right seeing ed revenue from
that I didn't say to you know GM hey
when she's put this course you don't
even have to pay for it right this is on
us and it seems like more and more it's
shifting to that kind of thing where
it's not regularly you know okay
tuesdays at eight o'clock and his
networking and we're sort of in the
middle generation which it was used to
watching appointment television right I
barely watch anything when I'm supposed
to watch anymore I a tebow everything I
download things to my ipod I'm you know
I'm I figured it out I like it better
ninety-five percent I want to watch his
tivo sometimes there'll be a game on
then i'll be watching live and it drives
me crazy where it's like oh he's coming
right on sundays you know my kids will
have their soccer games or something so
i go to those notifo the game and I come
home and I'll be watching it and I'm
kind of do all that stuff right those
long delays when they're reviewing a
play you know and there's a chance it's
like oh my god yeah well no I watch
those live it's like no one has its
bread truest amount of impatience yeah
absolutely so I just think the world has
changed
he can have it anywhere I mean that's
probably a big part of it you could be
on the train you can be in a bus you
know you can be in a park bench or
whatever you know to like your TV sit
around Leah wherever you're going you
know the Internet is change things it
kind of started you know maybe 10 years
ago when I think it was ice box with
those little those websites when the web
first sort of came to prominence that
were showing short cartoons you know
we're showing short pieces and they'll
really didn't work I mean no one really
came to watch them and I remember
thinking back then it's never gonna be
this is never gonna really happen people
are never going to do good internet to
watch short write anything now it's it's
obviously the future of the business and
even a friend on lost who is talking
about like lost it now being cut down
into mobis toads you know reading that
mobis ODEs people can watch them on
their on their cell phone and I don't
know what that is i don't think i would
watch that ah but I people are I very
much understand for what we do people
downloading the actual money from
downloads and the money from the new
media that is going you know that is
going to the conglomerates that we
certainly deserve I don't yet know
whether or not people are going to watch
you know whether we'll ever get paid to
actually sit and write five-minute
pieces that will that will actually
people will pay the watch right right no
one knows what the future holds really
right you know so maybe we will yeah
it's it's I think that's part of the
problem is the unpredictability yeah
about things and plus with the internet
i think you know you have to give credit
to porn at some point yeah
that's really been a big boom and that's
you know we can write that and it's not
gay you watch a 3 minute one of those
right sure that's in a sense but you
know like wait till you're talking we're
going out and there's a commercial
before I did thank you know this revenue
there that you know they've figured out
where that's coming from it they've got
that so uh all you to do is give a
percentage then if it makes them a
trillion dollars a year and you get a
small bday if it only makes them five
dollars a year and you still get the
small percentage it's it still works out
to be a fair share it's hard to see
their side really cuz they're making so
much money right and they keep telling
their advertisers and so on you know
they go these things that how much money
they're making and so on it's like yeah
but then you coming to us and telling us
how you're broke and so forth I
understand the excuse that we don't know
what's coming but no one's ever known no
one's ever yeah i mean this half of the
DVD situation sure sure I can't really
see their side and I know that after I
leave here I may never be heard from
again um I can't really sad with them
you